bella tutti ragazzi sei figo veramente
figo bella tutti ragazzi è benvenuto il
pacco grosse lamentele sono video sono
fa vj ci siamo su juan final break
ok non mi ricordavo il nome bene è un
videogame horror non si fosse capito da
questo bel ragazzo magro senza le dita
però col pene è ancora una demo e
ragazzi quindi non so bene il gioco
finale che è che tutti squilla il
telefono bionda cazzo stai godendo in
un'asta pagina che stanza brutta è
questa ma chiamate in corso l'ex ecco lo
so effettivamente non è la chiamata che
vorresti ricevere bravo bravo è un no è
un uomo cioè è stato bello capire posso
muovermi già che figo e un attimo ci
arrivi le considerazioni a 1 questo fuma
e tossici come la merda quindi non
dovrebbe farlo 2a che cazzo di merda
charles cos'è sta roba perché sei stato
lasciato però gesù un attimino napoli
tira ma potresti fare fantastico che
comunque è stato
interagisci con gli oggetti si ma lo
vedo un cazzo rega ma c'è una torcia in
questo gioco che mi sembra tutto bene ma
stai pagando 6 saltando bello sto
sensori meglio pensavo fosse solo lato a
camera così bella e complimenti
soprattutto rega
che cazzo sul servi spiegate perchè se
ma vicino a questo televisore esce
questa faccia bella mi servirebbe una
torcia perché non vedo cos'è sta roba
sei un ipad e un ipad questo si sa è
colato perfetto i miti prego che c'è la
batteria infinita perché non posso
farcela altrimenti da cosa ragazzi
andiamo avanti perché ami chiaro non è
possibile comunque complimenti anche se
successo che chi è che ha fatto chi è
che ha fatto store umore e brutti posso
entrare qua dentro
no perché il bello visto gioco che non
c'è un cazzo di audio se non ci fosse
complimenti anche per i bagni mio dio
da dove arrivano i rumori che non stop
dal cesso una paperella una paperella
nel cesso giusto ma con tutti i fottuti
posti dove potrei abitare ma proprio qua
la cosa più terrificante di questo posso
non è tanto la paperella nel bagno ma il
lavandino guardate che sguardo che
ciascun lavandini
fatemi fatemi uscire di qua perché non è
non è normale si può aprire questo c'è
una grazie a dio ce la fa a questa si
apre però ecco perché salve tasto
sinistro il tasto e per aprire sì l'ho
già capito sa buongiorno io adesso mi
dovete spiegare perché cazzo se questo
vive in una casa con dei manichini che
soffre di solitudine zio ma da morire
proprio ce l'hanno facebook almeno stima
di chi anche se che como dove non ti
preoccupare tanto vado io vado di qua si
è aperta la sua sta porta grazie esatto
esattamente quello che avrei detto io
zio bravata fucking cioè fatemi capire
chi è che ha lanciato un manichino dal
soffitto realtà fratello se non c'è
linea cos'è stop sul tasto so che cosa è
cambiato adesso questo tasto
comunque complimenti per l'arredamento
anche distanza no perché i manichini
dovete capire agazzi che hanno vita
propria
credo che loro siano più comodi di
quello in quella stanza un gap a prima
porta a porta perfetto era più semplice
di quanto pensassi tra l'altro fatemi
capire permesso se tagliato ragazzi un
manichino sia appena tagliato le vene
questo e non sta facendo un bagno
tranquillo con le paperelle ma chi è
bravo ascolta se tu non capisci un cazzo
di musica ok
è questa non capisci una serie di kakà
ma perché ci sono dei manichini in un
palazzo ragazzi che poi non è un palazzo
in manicomio questo ci va bene si
depressa e quindi devi vivere in una
casa di merda perché non pulisce
ma gesù santone che devono essere prese
anche i manichini a meno che pulisca al
nord mentre ragazzi non l'ho capita sarò
comunque andiamo avanti prima che fugge
giorno ascolti c'è una abbiamo trovato
alcuni film l'insegnante l'insegnante ma
sono già a scuola io e io pensavo di
essere a casa allora è tutto ecco perché
sono i banchi di scuola
comunque la vasca lavagna a scuola non
me la spiego io credevo di essere a casa
non tarda rachida mila porta in faccia
temi che appariva uno schiaffo che non
ha idea c'è una ragazzi ma io non l'ho
capito ma comunque c'è il costo che mi
dice dove andare va beh ma di te che
cazzo ne so io l'altro vado avanti con
sta roba ma non vedo un cazzo quindi
probabilmente sbatte contro i muri con
le facciate fantastica sinistra finita
finita perfetto salda ma questo era un
prima allora che cazzo serve cioè must
roba funziona mi dice sempre di andare a
sinistra non servono servono a segare
kasami c è infatti avranno nata o sei tu
l'obiettivo ma mi sa che sei proposito
mi il suo per esso dunque sei bello
ascolta visione hi fi sua porta come
cazzo ti permetto ho visto che ti sei
mosso lido presente cosa hai fatto che
mi chiama massimi che cosa fa della
taylor basta vuoi un ipad infatti cosa e
le finire qualche volta eventi mi ha
risposto manichino del cazzo
no vabbè ascolta ragazzi sei stato tu ti
ho visto o in ipad in testa brutto
stanno questo è un iphone o un ipad mini
catalogo e ti giuro che te lo do c'e un
passaggio ma bello ma [ __ ]
ancorato michele caputo ancora è
scollegato sto televisione fa a fare
casino
va bene la jean pierre da ragazzi di
abbado su perché mi sembra logico
permesso no io io vado impossibile vado
su perché ragazzi è il posto più bello
che potessi mai desiderare di trovata
altro era nascosti simo non l'avrei mai
visto buongiorno qualcuno ha ordinato la
pizza qui e se neanche mangiata io non
dormirei mai in questo può velocità
ma così così la pizza te la lascio
volentieri è la madonna la cosa mi fa
veramente piacere che perché possa
ordinare una pizza qualcosa c'è il
telefono stato scollegato anche quello
permesso entro c'è una freccia che
indica un pupazzo a gara un po pazzo ma
chi è quel monache chiude le porte basse
a livello la posta ai 60 secondi per
super fuggire cosa 5 ma cos'è una
trappola di solo questa ragazzi hanno
preso problema cosa è successo a 49 48
cosa è chiara
prendi questo so trovato un costo dei
libri non regga seriamente mimì aprite
stata già fatta
sono fuggito che chiude cosa o sono
morto non sono infatti è riuscito perché
dovevo uscire da lì il 60 secondi non
dall'edificio mica sonoro moltissimo di
ambientazione epica tranne il fatto che
ci sono dei money che si ma invece
tirarti le porte in faccia ma gesù
grazie
salve ma che combinato sexy che c'è
è un figo ha vinto tu ascoltami sei
veramente un film non sto scherzando
cosa devo fare
no no no no no no no no no no no no
notata da lontano ha dato ammazzo di
botte ti ammazzo ma poi mica che sei
ragazzi scherzano pure che mi chiude le
porte ma castro ma [ __ ] social
studiate porta in faccia
io devo solo uscire devo solo s'illude
che ti muovi facendo il sexy tanto non
ci casco pira una volta mi ha sedotto
non non capiterà mai più permesso si si
si si fa effetto bravo bravo bravo 3
premier per uscire dalla libreria hay
una libreria questa cosa che cazzo è
successo ma mai
salve le uscite una coppia di tua madre
bruta ma tu sei brutta anche con file a
breve demo è finita fanta complimenti
per l'ambientazione complimenti per il
mascara ma fai più pratica perché sei
brutto è stato bellissimo ma non ho
ancora capito perché un deficiente così
deve andare in un posto del genere anche
se c'è sua figlia me ne sbatte ray le
balle sinceramente però ognuno fa il
cazzo che vuole luca ragazzi concluso
quell'episodio è stato abbastanza
accorto quindi scusatemi però è la demo
ma il video è piaciuto così tracciato
momento mi piace se anche voi o di altri
manichini lasciato molto mi piace al
capo ieri facebook e condivido
transizione cioè se ne avresti discreti
che ci vediamo al prossimo video passa
da ragazzi vado a prendermi un tè non ce
la posso più fare